Oh man, he dropped. Man, they had this
little sevenyear-old boy coming up here
cussing, saying, "Unal alive this effing
Christian.
Unal alive this effing Christian." He
sound like he was like 11, 10 years old
in Islam
teaching the young kids to come up and
curse and advocate for the unaliving of
Christians. I have to say unal alive
because on Tik Tok, you know, they're
pretty sensitive.
Incredible.
But it's all good. All right, Tik Tok,
you're done. You're taking a break.
Let's bring up Axe. Axe, how you doing?
Hey, can you hear me?
I can mind turning down your mic a bit.
On or off?
Is it good now?
It's your mic is very very loud.
[__] Um,
don't worry. I I'll I'll try to handle
it. Say Say something now.
That's good now.
All right. Say something now.
Is that good?
All right. There we go.
Okay. So, first I want to apologize for
my bad English.
It's okay.
What's up?
I'm
live in Switzerland
next to France. Um, in fact, I was
raised Muslim,
born Muslim, and I have nothing wrong
with what Paul thought.
Can you hear me?
Yeah. Sorry. What' you say? You said um
you said what? I'm sorry I got
distracted by a super chat. It's weird.
Just um for me, Paul, it's
I have nothing bad with him.
It's just that I read the entire Bible,
Quran.
Mhm.
And there is a part of me that think
that Jesus is God.
Mhm.
But there is that what if what if my
fable interpretation of the Quran is
wrong and Allah is God. You know, you're
saying you're reading the Quran and some
parts of the Quran is leading you to
think Jesus is God.
No, no, no, no. I read the Bible
and the Bible.
Got it. Okay. You're reading the Bible
and you're saying that Jesus is God in
the Bible.
Yeah.
Okay.
And when I read the Quran, there is a
lot of things that tells me it is not
from God.
Yes.
Like the heaven, the commonal pleasure,
the contradictions,
etc.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So I'm just here and I don't know what
to do.
Who is God? I ask him. I I ask Jesus,
who are you? I ask Mari, who are your
son?
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. You're you're in a good
place actually. Um and the the one thing
that that I would say that you should do
the one thing that you should do is uh
you run towards the truth
and
don't suppress it when it it comes to
you. And I believe it has already come
to you, but you have a little bit of a
worry like you know, you have a worry
that you may be wrong about it or but
you obviously see the falsehood of the
Quran. You obviously see that it's not
from God, right? And so you're asking
then who is God? Right?
That's that's it.
So this is one way that you can see who
God is.
Um, and really it's it's one of my it's
actually my go-to this is my go-to way
of showing who God is and why it's it's
him, why it's the God of the Bible.
Because
one thing that we can rest on is that
God is consistent,
right? God is consistent and when he
sends prophets and messengers, they will
back each other up. They will be
consistent with each other. They won't
contradict each other. I know I raised
them up, guys. Say say hello to the to
the audience.
Can you hear me?
Right. There you go.
Can you guys hear them? Sounds loud loud
enough to me. Is it? Thumbs up. Can you
Was that good enough, guys?
We'll just We'll just wait for them to
respond just to make sure we're good to
go.
Thumbs up. Was that good, guys?
All right. Good. Cool.
All right. So, they will back each other
up, right? They they won't contradict
each other.
Yeah.
Now, so what is it? What that we can see
that it's the consistent message of the
prophets. If we can see a consistent
message of the prophets, then we can see
that God really spoke in real time. and
claimed to be who he said he was and
proved it. Something that we can point
to and say, "Yep, this is God. This is
his identity." And, you know, I have no
doubt about it. There's no worry, you
know, about who God actually is.
Yeah, I see.
And so, my thing is prophecy.
My thing is prophecy. So, like for
example, I'm going to take you I'm going
to show you a few things. I'm going to
show you Moses.
Okay?
I'm going to show you David.
I'm going to show you Isaiah.
Yeah.
And then finally, Jesus,
okay?
I'm going to show you the prophets.
And I'm going to show you that they have
a consistent theme, a consistent
message. Okay? Now, watch this. So,
we'll start with Moses in the Torah.
Okay? I'm pull it up. We're going to go
to Genesis chapter 3,
verse 15.
Hold on.
First clip here.
I'mma put it on the screen so we can all
see it too.
Yeah, I I cross reference referenced it.
It's about um the snake now.
Yes. Yes, you got it. That's right. Um
where's my where's my Bible?
I'm sorry. I'm sharing too many tabs
here. Oh, there it is. All right. There
we go.
All right. So, yeah, it's about the
snake. So, this is God speaking to the
snake after
um after Adam and Eve ate the fruit,
right? And they sinned against God. So,
now God is cursing the snake. And this
is what he says. The snake, which is the
serpent, the devil. This is what he
says. I will put enmity between you and
the woman
and between your offspring and her
offspring. Really, the the Hebrew word
is seed. Between your seed and her seed,
just to be more.
And he says, "He shall bruise your
head." So the seed of the woman, the
offspring of the woman will bruise the
head of the serpent while you shall
bruise his heel.
So in the meantime that the seed of the
woman is going to bruise the head of the
serpent going to crush his head while
the serpent is going to bruise his heel
at the same time.
Now
when we see this it says that the woman
has her own seed, her own offspring.
Who is the only woman? Because we know
that women don't have their own
offspring. Men plant the seed and women
give birth, right?
Yes.
But there's one woman who had her own
offspring, her own seed. Who is that?
It's Mary.
That's Mary.
Okay.
So, we see in the Torah, we see the
virgin birth talked about and how the
Messiah will crush the head of the
serpent while also being bruised.
Okay.
This is in the Torah. Now, let's see
what else the prophets say. Let's see
what else. Where else should we go?
Let's go to Isaiah. Let's see what
Isaiah says about the Messiah as well
because why
have you ever seen this before Isaiah?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. What' you think about it?
It's talk about Jesus.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
So even you see that it talks about
Jesus. And really anybody that I ask
they say it talks about they see it. Now
you already know this. So I I'll just
read a couple of verses just for
crushed for our iniquities.
Yeah.
All of that. So he's crushed for our
iniquities, pierced for our
transgressions, and the Lord lays on him
the sins of us all.
So Isaiah talks about how the Messiah
will be crushed. Pierced, right? Why
though? For us, for our sins, right? So,
we have Moses and we have Isaiah talking
about the bruising of the Messiah and
why the Messiah is going to be bruised.
Now, what about David? What does David
say? Psalm 22. Maybe you've heard of
this, too.
Psalm 22
starts off with, "My God, my God, why
have you forsaken me?" Familiar?
Yeah.
Jesus says this when he's on the cross.
Jesus points back to this psalm. We
scroll past, we see that he's getting
mocked. Verse eight, he trusts in the
Lord. Let him deliver him. Let him
rescue him for he delights in him.
Exactly what they were saying to Jesus
on the cross. They He claims to be the
son of God. Let him save himself. He was
able to perform miracles. Why don't he
come down? Right? God loves him. Let him
let God save him. That's what they were
saying to him on the cross. Right? Let's
scroll down a little bit. For dogs
encompass me. A company of evildoers
encircles me. They have pierced my hands
and my feet.
Isn't that insane?
Yeah. It's talking about Jesus.
Uhhuh. So you have David. Now mind you,
David is a thousand years before Jesus.
Yeah. Even in Psalm 101.
Oh, brother. You got it. You got it. So
you have David, Moses, Isaiah so far
talking about the piercing, suffering,
bruising of the Messiah for us. Here it
is again. Show you one more. Here's
Zechariah.
I don't know if you've probably seen
this one. Zechariah 12:10. I love this
one because this one
it's going to thy of God. No.
Yep.
Yeah.
God says, "And I will pour out on the
house of David and the inhabitants of
Jerusalem a spirit of grace and peace."
Oh, I'm sorry, and please for mercy, so
that when they look on me, this is God
speaking, "When they look on me, on him
whom they have pierced,
they shall mourn for him as one mourns
for an only child, and weep bitterly
over him as one weeps over a firstborn
son." When in the world did God get
pierced?
Yeah. In Calvary.
On Calvary.
So obviously, man, we see here that all
the prophets point to the crucifixion
and the bruising and piercing of the
Messiah for the sake of the world. And
that it's not just a man who's just a
good prophet who's getting pierced. It's
God himself who comes in the flesh to
redeem mankind. The prophets talked
about this
and Jesus says that he fulfilled it all.
Jesus said he fulfilled it all.
Consistency. Remember, we're talking
about consistency.
And and what makes this amazing is that
all of these prophets lived in different
generations.
Some of them a couple hundred years
apart from each other, right?
And yet you still see the common thread
with all of them.
Now here's Jesus in the gospel after he
resurrected and appeared to his
disciples. Then he said to them, "These
are my words that I spoke to you while I
was still with you that everything
written about me in the law of Moses,
the Torah, and the prophets, right?
Isaiah, Zechariah, Daniel, and the
Psalms, the Psalms of David must be
fulfilled." Then he opened their mouth
uh and then he opened their minds to
understand the scriptures and said,
"Thus it is written that the Christ
should suffer and on the third day rise
from the dead."
So how do you know who God is?
How do you know that God is who he said
he is? because he has shown himself not
only through creation but specifically
through prophecy
through special revelation of prophecy
showing that it's me the God of Abraham
Isaac and Jacob Yahweh the Lord of
heaven and earth father son and holy
spirit who revealed himself to mankind
revealed his redemption plan for mankind
his plan of salvation and it has been
consistent
through all the generations from the
Torah and with Adam and Moses all the
way to the gospel with Jesus and the
apostles.
But Muhammad contradicts everything we
just saw,
of course.
So Muhammad's out the window. He's gone.
It's a false prophet.
But this is how you know.
Make sense?
I mean, it's it's
a good argument for who is really God.
And there they they can't refute it.
They can't.
It's irrefutable.
Yeah. It's irrefutable. There's no
explanation for this. None. Now, here's
here's a fun thing because I was
actually just talking to the about this
with the Muslim. Um he said, "The Bible
is not the word of God. Prove it,
Avery." And I brought up the prophecy of
Isaiah 53. And he said, "Well,
um, how do you know that Isaiah wrote
it? We don't we don't know that Isaiah
wrote Isaiah." I said, "Let me even
grant you this. It's not true, but let
me just even let's just even say we
don't know who wrote the scroll of
Isaiah.
However,
whoever this author is prophesied the
crucifixion of Jesus,
his name is irrelevant. The fact that
his writing is a prophecy.
We even have the Dead Sea Scrolls.
Exactly.
The Greek book of Isaiah
in the com cave who is who Yeah. Minus
73 AD.
That's right. So they're about 200 years
before Jesus.
Yeah.
So brother, like it it sounds to me that
you you know you've studied this, you've
looked at this.
Yeah. Yeah. I I and yeah I studied the
Bible but
always that what if
you know in the deep of my heart I hope
that God is Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
Well let me uh show you what the Bible
says this man so that you don't feel
you know any doubt or shame for doubting
or anything like that. Let me show you
what I I just read this verse earlier
too by the way. But here it is.
It's Romans chapter 10:es 9-11.
It says, "Because if you confess with
your mouth that Jesus is Lord and
believe in your heart that God raised
him from the dead, you will not maybe,
not might, you will be saved. For with
the heart one believes and is justified.
You believe this in your heart, bro?
You're justified. You're good. And with
the mouth one confesses and is saved.
For the scripture says, "Everyone who
believes in him will not be put to
shame."
Case closed.
You put your faith in Christ Jesus,
believe in him as your Lord, and you
will not be put to shame.
No what if.
You're not going wrong here.
Yeah.
So may the Lord erase any doubt in your
in your mind, any what if and any fear
to be put to shame on judgment day
because you believed in the gospel and
that Jesus was God.
We we we pray that God gets rid of all
of that and casts that out.
Thanks.
Right.
And
you know,
you have confidence that you will not be
put to shame at all
at all in any way, shape, or form. Look
at what this verse says here. This is
Mark chapter 9 vers 24. I showed this to
uh another brother um Monday, last
Monday. And he uh he ended up you know
coming to faith because he he also had
this conviction that the gospel was true
and that Jesus was God and that you know
Jesus teachings was the truth. But what
if and you know but he believes but he
has unbelief right and so this was uh
where a man had his child was suffering
from a demon and
Jesus asked him do you believe
and immediately the father of the child
cried out and said I believe but help my
unbelief.
It's okay to have the doubts or a little
bit of unbelief, but bring it to him.
Bring it to the fa to the feet of the
Lord and he will solve it. He'll cure
you of all the doubts and be with you.
Give you assurance. Give you confidence.
It's hard.
Yeah,
it's hard.
So
what I would do is bro,
I would say choose today.
Choose today who you serve.
Choose today. Ask God to help your
unbelief. You believe. I can hear it.
You even said it. But Lord, help my
unbelief.
Help me where I where I disbelieve the
where the doubt is. Help me. Lord, help
me. and he will I think he's done that
today.
It's difficult
because I have to
Man, I'm going to cry.
It's all right, man.
It's all right.
It's all right. Go ahead. In the deep of
my heart, I
I know I I I I do not know, but I hope
that Jesus is Lord
because
he
he is such a beautiful example.
Absolutely.
For mankind and
and all the biblical it's it's logical.
It's logical. It's consistent,
right? It has evidence to back it up.
But it's it's interesting that you say
like it's logical like it's true and you
and you have this hope, but sometimes
there is a there is a spirit a spiritual
block
that
Yeah.
Satan Satan or the devil puts on us to
doubt,
right? It causes our hearts to and I
this is why I'm like man bro the
scriptures is lit God is talking to you
today bro I'm serious look at this look
at what Jesus says he's he literally is
answering every all of your concerns
look he literally is talking to you says
let not your hearts be troubled
believe in God believe also in me
and my father's house are many rooms
If it were not so, would I have told you
that I go to prepare a place for you?
And if I go and prepare a place for you,
I will come again and will take you to
myself that where I am, you may be also.
This is his promise to us. And the only
thing we have to do, brother Acts, is
believe.
or even Jesus Christ.
That's it.
It's all we got to do.
He says, "Let not your hearts be
troubled." But he doesn't just leave you
there. He gives you a promise.
Yeah.
And a conviction on why your heart
shouldn't be troubled when you put your
faith in him.
Because he will always be with me.
He'll be with you. Not just will he be
with you, but as we speak, he's
preparing a room for you in his father's
house. And he says he will personally
escort you to that room. He will bring
you to him. That's what he says.
And all we all we have to do is say,
"Yes, Lord. I believe
that's it.
That's all he says.
All we have to do is come to him and lay
it all before him.
That's all we got to do, brother. And we
won't and we will not be put to shame.
Look what he says here. He continuing to
encourage us.
Continue. Look like if you if he ain't
talking to you today, I don't know who's
talking to you, man. Matthew 11 verse
28. Look what he says here. Come to me.
Come
all who labor and are heavy laden
and I will give you rest. This is this
is what he promises us, man. He's not
lying to us. He says, I will give you
rest. Come to me.
He says, "Take my yoke upon you and
learn from me, for I am gentle
and lowly in heart, and you will find
rest for your souls." Come on, man. For
my yoke is easy and my burden is light.
You'll never find anything like this in
Islam, Hindu, nothing.
Quite the opposite.
Quite the opposite, man. It's the exact
opposite.
It's the opposite. Lord, help his
unbelief. Help H help my unbelief.
I accept you as Lord. I believe you are
Lord. I trust in you for my salvation.
Help my unbelief.
And lay it before him.
What do you think, man? You ready to lay
it before Jesus today?
I think
Well, today is the day, man.
Today is the day. And from this day
forward, let him take your hand through
this journey and continue to encourage
you and give you assurance and blow your
mind. You the I'm telling you, the more
you learn about G, the second you say,
"Yes, Lord, I trust you completely.
I trust you completely.
The second you do that, he takes you by
the hand and he walks with you day in
and day out, night in night out, and you
begin to fall more in love with him. You
begin to see what he desires of you. And
your heart begins to get formed like his
heart and you want what he wants. You
want to do what pleases him. You want to
do things that glorify him. and you just
want to make him known to others. That's
the miracle of salvation. Like the
gospel changes us from the inside out.
Many
racing.
Yeah.
Choose today, man.
I can I can uh if you if you want, I can
help you. Uh, you want to confess Lord
as your savior today? You can do it
today here if you want or you can, you
know, do it in your own time. It's what,
you know, it's up to you.
I'm going to confess.
You want to confess? Okay. Glory to God,
guys. God is uh, man, God is working.
God is working, man. It's It's so
beautiful. Glory to God. All right, let
me ask you these questions, my brother.
Yes.
Do you believe that Jesus Christ is your
Lord and Savior?
Yeah, I believe that Jesus Christ is my
Lord and Savior.
Do you believe that he died for your
sins?
I believe that he died for my sins.
And do you believe that God raised him
up on the third day?
Yeah. Jesus Christ rose from the dead.
That's right.
and you trust in him for your salvation
and him alone.
Amen, brother.
Today and this and at this moment,
God has grafted you in into his family.
And now you are not just a servant or a
creation of God, but you are now a son
of God. You have been adopted as a son
of God. And the Bible says this in John.
It says for those who believed on his
name on the name of the son of God
perish but have everlasting life
and have everlasting life. But not just
that he said it says that he has given
them right to be called sons of God.
Yeah.
Not by blood, not by the will of man,
but born of God. You're born again
today, brother.
And I say welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to the family of of of Christ.
Man,
man,
out out of everybody all the live
streams, you almost you almost got a
tear out of me, but you're not gonna do
it today. You tried, but not gonna do
it. Not going to do it. Not happening
today, man. Glory to God,
God. Man, have your will in this man's
life. We thank you for this new brother.
We pray Lord that you encourage him,
that you increase him in his faith. That
your Holy Spirit not only is dwelling in
him now, but fills him up, that he is
filled up with boldness and courage and
excitement and joy for your name's sake,
God. And that he lives his life in
gratitude to you for saving him, for
calling him, and drawing him in.
We pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
Amen.
Brother, welcome. Welcome to the family,
man.
Oh my goodness, guys. Do you guys see
what is happening here?
You guys see what is happening here?
Just yesterday, a Muslim also came to
Christ, man.
Yeah, I see that.
You saw that?
Yeah.
And then today, now you join and more
and more are gonna keep coming, man,
because God is real.
Jesus is real. There's nobody like him.
No competition among the false gods.
None.
Hallelujah.
Glory to God. Man, I thank God for you,
man. I thank God for
I thank God and thank you.
Amen.
I thank God, man. You are obedient, man.
You You obeyed the call and here you
are, man. You're a son of God just like
the rest of us. It's a brother in the
faith. So here's the next step. Next
step you want to do, try to find, get
baptized, right? Yep.
And keep in touch with us. Like just
because you come to the faith now, like
there, you know, don't be a stranger.
Keep coming. Like if you have questions
or even something that excited you about
what you read and some not, come come
share it. We want to know. We want to
hear it.
Okay.
For sure. All right. Well, if that's it,
man, if that's all I could do for you,
you know, that's good for me,
man. God bless you, brother. Uh, stay in
touch.
God bless you.
Are you on Instagram or on Facebook and
stuff like that?
Uh, I don't want to share it now.
That's fine. But if you if you know
mine, Mine Mine is in the description.
So, if you want to reach me, try to
reach me on any of those. Okay.
Okay. Thanks.
God bless you, Billy, man.
God bless you.
All right. Take care. Take care.
Ah, wow.
Wow. Glory be to God. Two days in a row.
Two days in a row. Last Monday,
yesterday and today. God is working in
this ministry. God is working in this
ministry.
God is working in this ministry. Ladies
and gentlemen, we are seeing firsthand
the Holy Spirit work, actively work live
through these conversations.
We are seeing it firsthand, guys.
We are seeing it firsthand.
Lives are being transformed,
minds are being changed, hearts are
being reshaped into the image of God,
into the image of the of of Christ,
and they are accepting the gospel,
the truth of Christ. It's he's so
evident, so clear, so real,
and there is nobody
like him.
Nobody.
That's right. Andrea says he will never
be alone. Jesus is with him. God bless.
That's right.
Leica says, "My brother, welcome to the
kingdom. I promise you, you won't regret
it. Amen.
And Bit says, "Man, this channel is just
beautiful." Glory to God.
Jason in the house. He says, "What an
amazing time to be alive." That's right.
And now we have a new brother who was
born again and is alive in Christ with
us, man.
Wow. Kalam says, "Let's go." Yeah, this
is exciting, guys.
This is exciting. Everybody on Tik Tok
is celebrating as well. We got uh you
know over 2100 people on YouTube
celebrating.
Man, to God be all the glory. Welcome,
Axe, our new brother in Christ. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Amen.